but the problem is I want a healthy
government and if that means it needs to
slim down because the government has
become obese I'm okay with the
government going on a workout program
that's the problem I don't agree if the
government wants to preserve itself it
needs to take itself seriously and
restructure itself
that's why we need to restructure from
time to time how do we do that well the
vicarama Swami suggests that we cut the
FBI I think it's the FBI and then send a
lot of the you know fire a lot of the
administrators administrative guys you
know but then move a lot of the
necessary pieces to other parts of
government Homeland Security CIA
um Department of energy he has it listed
in fact and I retweeted it it's on
Twitter I'd love to point you to it I'm
on I'm on the same page with you homie
Vivek is great like I think that he's a
great candidate and I think nobody ever
say his name the cake man we gotta call
him the cake man because it's the vague
like cake